[Music]
So try to understand like um you need
confirmation exercises. Okay.
Um a lot of what we do are confirmation
exercises. So this is uh within the cook
cultivation set there each one that
follows is a confirmation exercise for
the one that preceded it. Okay. And this
variation on the set is a confirmation
for the that whole set. So um but this
is going to really help you Sean and
Bouching and then fine-tune the other
people. Okay. Um, it deals with the
segmentation that we were having
problems with yesterday on the jok or
even on the um um the throw that we were
doing. Okay. So, this one is not going
to be in the in the arm. So, I am on the
back foot and I am doing the same drill.
Same thing. Let go really fast and I
won't go flying forward. Okay. What we
might tend to see is this rotation.
Okay. Or this hinge. So the either I'm
rotating around the the spine this way
or the top hinge on the quad is not
being organized. Okay. All right. So
let's try it.
You're still pushing. You're still
pushing as hard as you if you if you
push light, you're not going to get the
discovery you need. Okay?
It's just like the punching yesterday.
It was too light for your guys' level of
sensitivity.
So, we're seeing the top the top hinge
is weak. But sometimes you come
sometimes you you show up here and
you're you're all like this. It was it
was even in the in the hand you were
doing. Okay. You you have to put your
yong aspect has to start on the on the
midfoot. It's not that I'm I'm over
here. You see when when I'm like this
and I'm falling forward and just
microflexing to keep myself up. Okay? So
my body has to be on the midfoot. Now
that doesn't mean be upright cuz that's
going to put you on the heel. Okay? But
I can't be forward of it either. Okay?
Go.
And so and practice when you're pushing
Virginia, put his yong back on your
midfoot. Don't don't c cave your chest
in.
All right. So, something to note here. I
don't know. I I'll have to watch on the
video. I don't know what. But so, let's
say you're here and you're leaning into
him. Do Do you see that? You're You're
kind of doing that here, too. You guys
are like this and that's what's caving
your chest. You rest on that. And then
his energy goes down to the back foot.
Not
you're trying to do that. Okay. And try
it again.
Oh, you were doing it with your hands,
but it's more noticeable now.
Don't push your shoulders forward or
your chest will cave.
Dip your chin. The crown of the head is
the top.
There's rotational there's rotational
weakness here. And you should you if I'm
here like this. You see it's right here.
You see? Did I did that take a lot of
effort on my part? No. Okay. And I can
see it from over there. But you are not
doing what I'm saying. I told you
increase the feedback so that he can
discover. Okay, we're not here jacking
each other off.
Don't cave your chest.
You're You got the uh spaghetti. You're
You're relaxing too much and it pushed
your shoulders back.
He's too upright. You're too federite.
We're not upright.
Watch the rotational weakness, James.
The top hinge is fine, but the
rotational weakness is not there. The
rotational organization is not there.
You got to sink. Just picking you up.
Drop. Pull your lats down.
The top link. The top one.
Don't. So, here's here's what I mean,
Virgin.
And it's the same thing
uh when we were doing this, right? When
we were all learning this and then I'm
saying relax, relax. And you guys go and
then it goes back. You got it? And then
we say not PJs. That's what I mean. Cuz
you look like you look like you put your
cozies on. Do you know what I mean? Like
little kids. Okay. So, and we started
using the words release. You're just
releasing inside, which has nothing to
do with the outside. Okay. So, the same
thing is happening to you here. You're
trying to relax, but you're letting them
push you back. Do do you get that? So
you you could be here. I could I could
position here and do the same releasing
because it doesn't matter in into the
form. Do you understand? Do you get
that? Okay. So, but I'm trying to set
you up for success. So, I want you here,
but I don't want you push. I don't want
you doing that. Do you see that? Okay,
that's you're that's not that's the
difference between
being organized. We got to draw these
distinctions. It's organized. That's
what we want. A particular way. Um
we don't want to be relaxed. Do do you
see that? Okay. Because releasing is not
about necessarily relaxing.
Releasing doesn't have a shape to it.
Okay. All right. Try it again.
Take dip your chin.
Top top qua
watch your eyes
your eyes. Don't look down.
Top qua.
Top qua
chest up.
Okay.
So, remember that I said on this drill,
the
the metric you want isn't that you
didn't move backwards.
The metric that you want is under the
pressure you released.
Do you got it? Okay. Now, the problem is
I don't know what release is. I don't
know what it feels like. So that's
that's why we're here and that's why you
have to spend so much time all that kind
of stuff. Okay. But for you,
you know what release feels like and you
have just have to make that your goal.
Okay. So when you're here like that,
let's say you're you are going oh okay I
oh I I tense. Do you understand? So when
you get here and you're not moving, you
release. You feel that difference? So
that when that way I'm not here and then
you let go and I go flying forward.
Maybe I had to uh organize. Do you know
what I mean? But when I'm here,
I'm letting go. Then you let go and I
don't go flying forward. Okay. Got it.
Okay. Try it.
midfoot, not arch.
Whoa.
You're all cattywampus.
You're very Your hips are all weird. You
have like a Look, you're like going like
this.
What?
Thank you.
[Music]
Look at this.
So on that drill, on that side, Andrew,
don't push that hip out like that.
If you have that S, there's no way
you're on the midfoot. You need the
verticality of the gra of the
gravitational descending.
Let go real fast. Let go real fast.
Don't shoot that hip out.
[Music]
Oh,
[Applause]
[Music]
What are you going to do?
Lock those shoulders in place.
All right. Uh
comments
It feels like lost is not the right word
but just today I'm not finding many of
the organizations
lower feel very tense and there's almost
this sort of perceived like when the
push comes in there's already almost
thought of I'm not going to make it okay
let's let's break that down a little bit
okay
I started out by saying this is a
confirmation exercise for the other set.
Okay. What does that tell you about this
set in terms of difficulty to the last
set? It's more difficult. Okay. So, you
it's kind of
it it doesn't make sense for us to go
today. I'm not able to organize.
I I'm not able to organize in the other
set. That is why I'm now seeing it here
in this set. Do do you get that? What is
the difference? This one is more
amplified
and I can now see what's there.
It was there in the first set. Do do you
guys understand? It's not going to help
you if we if we're like today I have a
off day. That's not how we think. Okay.
Um
so it's just amplified enough that I can
now see it. We we again go back. You're
like I don't know. I think today I just
have an off day, you know. See,
whatever. Somehow I was able to pull you
from before
I even told you
to do the technique
that I knew wasn't going to work
yesterday. Do you see that? Does
everyone see that? That would be
predictability, but it's not psychic.
It's just the organization is not there.
I'm going to go through you. I'm not
going to bounce off of you. Do you get
that? Again, you might want to go, well,
you weigh more than me or whatever, but
Virginia is probably weighs less than
you and she's projecting people. It
doesn't take that much force to displace
that amount of mass that has already
been disorganized from the otoshi. Do do
you get that?
Um, this is all accurate. When we start
talking about today, I'm not able to
organize. This is not accurate. I can't
do anything with that. I can't move
forward from inaccurate information.
Okay. Um again, if you look at the
statement when I said before, I go this
is going to be particularly insightful
and beneficial for you and for Sean
because you guys don't have this yet
even at the hands. Okay. Um
again, how did I know that prior to the
drill? because I can see it in the other
drill. Okay,
same thing again. Another example. How
did I know if I just lightly press more
than you, the rotational compromisation
would occur? Do you see? I'm not
guessing. I can see it. Okay, which
means it's there. All right. Um
and we we're when you have a
confirmation drill,
a confirmation drill
is of such a nature that cultivation
might not be possible in that drill. Do
do you get it? It's just too difficult.
Um,
and you have to go back to the other
drill with the awareness from the other
confirmation drill. You can't sit here
and go, I'm just going to practice this
more. You It's too difficult. You're not
You're not going to get it. Okay. It it
would be it would be like for example
with Tristan
um you know when he f when I was first
teaching him to shoot he wanted to learn
three-pointers and I said dude you can't
shoot from four feet off we're not going
to do three-pointers we'll learn the
mechanics up close do do you see um and
uh
and now he now he can sink the three. So
you you can't there there's just too
much human variation and and deviation
that occurs as the as the thing is more
difficult. No different again like you
want to you want to shoot and be
accurate at 25 yards. The new the new
recruits always think I need more
practice at 25 yards. There's too it's
too difficult there. the variables are
too too um too numerous for us to fix
the mistakes. Let's hit at let's
practice at three yards. Do you see? If
you can put bullet holes and bullet
holes at three yards, then you're going
to hit the 25 yard. Do you see that? Um
so same thing here. This is too
difficult a cultivation field, but it
does function as a confirmation field.
Okay. So,
and I think we're getting what we're
want out of this. In other words, and
let me show you the futility of this. We
might as well do it. Okay?
Just because I want you to understand
you have to know how to train yourself.
Okay? So, here here we are, right? Okay.
And then now we're gonna have the same
thing. Do you see? All right. Let's try
let's try drill two.
What what do you what can you predict is
going to happen in drill two and why?
Okay, now why the skill level required?
How? What? Come on, be an engineer. Tell
me what part is making it more
difficult?
Okay, where are more forces coming from?
Come on. Come on. Explain it. What's
going on?
We've got more momentum behind the mass.
Okay. So there's going to be more what
at contact force more force there
because the opposing energy. Do you do
you understand? So we come up bouncing.
Okay. And we do the the first drill.
Okay. And here here I am.
This is going to be amplified. You're
going to project me back. Do you see?
Do do you guys get it? So there's no
we're not you no point in doing drill
two and then no point as you go on and
on. There's like no because the force
equations become harder to navigate for
these reasons that they become amplified
as you're going up and we're taking away
as we go higher in the drills your
bracing angle. Do you see that? So we're
weakening your force engine as we're
increasing their force. There's no
there's no way. Okay. And that's why we
don't do it. This is not how to
cultivate. Is it pretty interesting?
Yeah, it's pretty interesting. But at
the same time, if I could do the first
drill set, this is this is not a big
deal. Do do you get it? It's like so no
point in doing it. There's other things
uh that are more interesting.
Um and which is the the two edges of
this sword. It's like um there's so much
self in the hands, in the arms, in our
consciousness. Okay? And so that's why
it's important that you learn how to do
the set as it's first prescribed to you.
Okay? Um
so let's uh know for example that we
have this
okay we have this confusion between
relaxing and releasing and we have this
okay
uh and then we also have okay once I get
positionally
uh stabilized I should go inside my body
and release the tension. Okay. All right
let's try it.
We're with two hands now.
Two hands. Back to the hand, the hand
variation, the hands set. But feel those
turning forces, those tilting forces.
You can let go real quick.
You got to release.
I can't just release on good days.
[Music]
What?
You don't like it?
[Music]
Come here.
Look.
Okay, come on back
here. And
okay, uh, Virginia, you had something.
Well, you were going to say something.
especially
not
on the front or the back leg.
On both. Okay.
Okay.
All right. Um,
how about on this now with the hands?
Are you able to feel what got amplified
in the other drill? No. Okay. Uh, so
let's let's push on James with the
shoulder drill.
Wait, let him set up. He's got to put
his yong on there.
So, so already I can tell. Okay. The
rotational angle is not there
and he's leaning forward. You see he's
leaning forward. So Sean, let's go
quickly when he wants.
Well, we pushed him past it and he came
back to neutral,
which you should have been able to feel.
We're barely hanging on right now. Okay.
So, where do you where then? There's
that. Okay. So go back. Go a little
slower and a little longer.
Okay. And where do you feel flexion?
That's what I want
is the first question.
The back of your right leg. Okay. And
we'll keep pressing. And where do you
feel flexion?
Okay. Now go back. Come back out, Sean.
And now go back. Feel the flexion. And
then I want you to re relax that
flexion. Relax, not release. Okay. Do
you got it?
Okay.
Let's deal with the lower ab flexion.
Okay. Tell me when you feel the flexion.
If you need more force, he'll give you
more force slowly.
Okay. And now relax that flexion. Sean,
you keep that pressure. Relax it more.
What's happening to your body?
Okay.
Keep it relaxed.
Is the flexion there?
Okay. And uh as I'm talking, Sean,
whenever you want, you'll quickly let
go.
Okay.
So, let's try it again.
So there's that. Okay. So I'm barely
pushing and um right that was barely
touched you. Okay. Um
you have to be able to feel that. Okay.
All right. You're doing it again.
What I what you're doing is you're
you're leaning into your shiaku. Okay.
And it is to stop the it's to stop that
rotational weakness there. Okay. There
you go. All right.
Careful. Don't lean in the shikaku.
Okay. So, there there is that reason
you're flexing the abdominals. Okay. So,
flex your abdominals again. Yeah. Okay.
Got it. Unflex them again. And what what
do you feel when you do that difference?
My scar. Yeah, you're going backwards.
Okay. So, here, flex it again. Okay. And
there I'll keep that pressure. Right.
And then release that. Release it.
And you're going in that shikaku again.
There's the hinge. It's right there.
Okay.
Got it. Okay. So, we got two things.
We we have a rotational weakness
and we have this hinge weakness. And
your rotational solution is to lean this
way. Okay?
Which is exposed when we
let go. You're just you're just falling
that way. Do you see? Okay. And then the
other one is this hinge one, which your
solution is flex here. Do do you
understand? Okay. So now we're here.
And you want to feel for those two
pseudo solutions. So you're you're
already doing it. Okay. You're already
Can you guys see that? Yeah. So you can
see how he moves that way. Okay.
And there's the h there's the the You're
coming up over the top. Do you see?
Okay. Stay here. Stay where you are. And
now without moving from where you are.
Do you understand? Don't move in space.
Start to release that tension. Don't
move from where you are.
Start to release that tension. There you
go. Same thing. It's going to go in
waves. It's fine. And you just keep
releasing that. Don't lean backwards.
You keep releasing the tension.
Keep releasing it
while staying where you are. Notice how
the breath changes stuff still for you.
Okay.
Stay there. Stay there.
What? Stay there. Don't start leaning
backwards.
Okay. What you're What he's doing now
has nothing to do with me. His yong
aspect is doing that. Stay there.
Watch the breath not taking you. Take
stay with this feeling. I'm going to
move. You stay there. Stay right where
you are. Don't lean backwards.
Stay right there. Stay right there. has
nothing to do with me. Stay right there.
Your own body is doing it. Stay right
there. Stay right there. Stay right
there. Don't Don't go. Don't Don't be
influenced by my lack of pressure. Stay
right there.
Stay right there. Stay right there.
Don't let your arms come forward. They
stay right where they're at.
Stay. Stay.
Stay.
Stay. Stay. Don't. It doesn't change
anything.
Stay. You're leaning back. Don't lean
back.
Stay. Let it sink.
Don't go to Shikaku. Just stay there.
[Music]
Good. Okay. Cuz I'm pushing pretty hard
at the end, right? Okay. So,
again, it doesn't have to do with shape.
It doesn't have to do with your partner.
Those are just amplification tools.
Okay. Um,
what I was doing and what you felt is I
started with pressure to get you there
and then I'm releasing right there. that
the hands were just decreasing in the
pressure onto you to the point where
they could let go and then it doesn't
matter where you're where you're being
touched. Dude, that's what we were
doing. But while we while you felt me
decrease,
what did you tend to do as my light as
my grip started getting lighter?
Let's try it again. So, you can see this
is that I'm not sensitive enough. I
don't know what I did. Okay. So, we'll
go again. Okay. We'll get you there.
Don't fall into shiaku.
You're falling into shitaku.
Okay.
Feel the flexion in your arms.
Then they got relaxed. Okay. Why' they
relax? A sympathetic. Yes. Cuz I I
relax. Do you see that? And it can't be
like that. Okay. So that's what I'm
constantly telling you. Don't don't
don't don't don't because you're going
into PJ mode. Okay. So
again, what I'm doing here is amplifying
the forces enough for you to become
aware of them. So everyone else got
aware of them from the shoulder drill,
but you're over here looking like I
don't know. And then we could see,
right? You didn't know with your hands.
And then you got to we can't get around
the training equations. You're barely
training now. So there's no sensitivity
or as much sensitivity as someone else.
Okay? So you have to put the time in. Uh
it has to be done wisely. You can't get
lost in today I'm not doing it. You got
it? All that stuff. Okay. Um so let's go
back to this drill and try to feel
what's actually happening to you. It's
not magic. If it's not luck of the draw,
like Tristan used to do that, like my
shot is off. No, your shot is not off.
Your mechanics, you're not doing your
mechanics. That is all what it means.
Okay? Um, it's not luck whether you hit
the target with your round or not. Do
you know what I mean? You change the
mechanics. So, what I always tell the
recruits is every time your round is
somewhere else, it's because you change
your mechanics. you just aren't aware of
how you're changing your mechanics,
okay? Or to what degree. So, very
similar here. We It's an awareness
issue. Okay. All right. Let's try the
hand drill.